first of all are just interested in
hearing your view on to what extent the
this plan by the government to to
protect people from the worst rises in
in Energy prices what difference that's
going to make to people it comes in
effect because tomorrow when prices are
due to go up absolutely tomorrow I mean
if the government hadn't done this let's
be clear it would have been totally
apocalyptic the level of price Rises
they would have seen because of those
changes in the wholesale Market that off
gem had this mechanism that would have
passed that on to all of us households
so the government really needed to do
something it's a very big package
um but the trouble is it doesn't get all
the way there so we've got the 400
pounds that's going to be split over the
next six months that will be going to to
everyone and then there's this new cap
on energy bills now the average
household with average consumption that
means their bill would be 2 500 pounds
but the really important thing to
understand is that is average
consumption if you use more absolutely
if you're if you're a bigger house if
you've got a bigger family it will be
higher than that and obviously if you've
got smaller a property you know better
insulation whatever it will be smaller
than that it's not not an overall cap on
bills so what you're actually using over
the winter is going to make a huge
difference even with that government
protection and if we compare to where we
were last winter even with all this
government protection the bills are
still looking around double what they
were before so households are still
under major pressure well yes and your
surveys found that hasn't it that there
are some people who are really going to
have to make some difficult decisions
still even with his help absolutely I
mean it shows us our research is saying
that pretty much all of us are really
thinking about how we can pull back on
usage about 5 million households one in
five so that unless they really do pull
back uses they won't make it through the
winter and one in ten think even with
doing all of that they're still going to
really struggle so we shouldn't think
like the pressure over the winter has
gone on energy it very much is still
there and there still is action the
households will need to take to make it
through so what kind of action can they
take so at u-switch we've got three
things we're advising customers to do
check track change so first on check
make sure your meter readings are up to
date it's really important to do that
when the rates go up especially if you
don't have a smart want me to get those
into your supplier around now why is
that so important because when rates go
up if the supply has to estimate the
bill it's quite possible the usage
you've already used will get charged at
the higher rate and you don't want to
get in that situation then the next one
is track I know a u-switch we've brought
out a new app called utrack which is
going to connect up to people that got
smart meters more than half of us have
those and show all the information about
what I'm using when give you the hints
tips and tell you how you might be able
to reduce the usage in ways that you
don't have to make the worst possible
decisions of just shutting everything
off and the last one is change it's not
going to get us all the way there but
the reality is a lot of us are going to
have to change consumption to make it
through the winter and even if we don't
have to a lot of us are looking to save
money it's not like the pressures aren't
there on other areas of household bills
as well so that's things like you know
use the information on tracking to to
make those adjustments turn your
thermostat down don't use appliances you
don't have to all of that we're still
looking at all of that this winter it's
still going to be difficult well yes and
obviously the main thing is people need
to be able to to eat they need to be
able to use their their cooking
Machinery appliances and they also want
to heat their home so what other savings
can be made is there awareness of what
can be done I mean I think pretty much
all households are aware they really
need to do something here I think what
we're trying to do at u-switch is by
giving you the data of exactly what's
happening in your house you might be
able to identify stuff that's easy to
turn off and doesn't mean you have to
make the worst possible decisions but
then you also need to look at can I use
appliances less can I use a microwave
instead of an oven can I turn the
thermostat down a couple of degrees
these are the things that can start to
make a material difference you'll start
to save hundreds of pounds if you're if
you're really focused on making sure
you're not wasting energy